hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
section 11 of David hume's inquiry
concerning human understanding is
entitled of Providence and a future
State and the the main interest in this
section about the possibility of a
future state has to do with this notion
of justice and so if we think that there
is a providential ordering of things
then what we should see is some sort of
Justice in a substantive sense either in
the arrangement of the universe as we
experience it or put off to some future
State and Hume is actually going to be
combating these by placing arguments in
the mouth of his friend and epicurus who
his friend is giving voice to you could
say but these are actually hume's own
arguments so the first place to look in
this is this discussion of the
epicureans and the you know this is
epicurus defending himself to the
Athenians and he says I deny a
Providence you say and supreme governor
of the world who guides the course of
events and punishes The Vicious with
infamy and disappointment and rewards
The Virtuous with honor and success in
all of their undertakings and this is
indeed the way some people view
providential ordering of the universe by
some good and just actually superb
superlatively good and just God and the
epicureans rejected that the epicureans
by the way didn't think there were no
gods they just thought that the gods
don't care about human beings and that's
why the gods are so happy because they
just do their God things often some
other place and they leave us here in
this world which is you know largely
governed by interactions of matter and
then Randomness and stuff like that so
you know the epicureans get charged as
being atheists as denying Providence and
they actually do deny Providence they
don't think that there's any sort of
intelligent arrangement of the world
other than perhaps in human affairs
but epicurus at least in this thing is
saying that doesn't really matter
because you can still have a commitment
to all the things that people who claim
that they care about Justice and think
that there could be reward and
Punishment all the things that they say
matter so he says
I don't deny the course itself of events
which lies open to everybody's inquiry
and examination I I'm fine with looking
experientially at the world and
reasoning from that and what can I
actually reason about in human Affairs
he goes on and he says I acknowledge
that in the present Order of Things
virtue is attended with more peace of
mind than Vice so you know you're not
going to get some absolute reward for
being virtuous but there's a tendency if
you are virtuous if you're behaving like
a decent person you know the virtues
that the epicureans recognize were the
same four cardinal virtues wisdom
Justice Temperance courage that the
stoics or the platonists and also the
aristotelians in their own way
acknowledged as well so virtue it's not
its own reward but it does have a
tendency to you could say pay off and
vice
um you know is going to make you uneasy
of mind right he says virtue is attended
with more uh peace of mind and vice
meets a more favorable reception from
the world and also friendship friendship
is the chief Joy of human life I mean
historically the epicureans did think
this right epicurus himself says that
friendship is a a great valuable thing
and moderation uh he says is the only
source of tranquility and happiness he
goes on he says I never balance between
The Virtuous and vicious course of life
I'm sensible that to a well-disposed
mind every Advantage is on the side of
the former The Virtuous life so even if
you don't believe in a providentially
organized Universe you can still behave
like a good person you can be virtuous
you can cultivate friendships you can
engage in moderation you can be happy so
that's that's one important thing that
he's pointing out
what if you take the other point of view
though and you say well there is a
providential ordering of things you know
God cares about the universe and sets
things up in the right way so if we
affirm that there is Divine Providence
in the world
then we have to ask
um you know is there indeed a supreme
distributive justice in the universe and
he says well
I mean if I did believe that then I
would expect the reality that I'm
experiencing to be at least a little
different than I'm actually noticing it
to be he says I want to expect some more
particular reward of the good and
Punishment of the bad beyond the
ordinary course of events and then he
says I find here the same fallacy which
I have before endeavored to detect and
what is this fallacy arguing from effect
what it is that we see in the universe
to a cause so in this case we think that
there's some order some you know Justice
some organization of things we we argue
to a Supreme Being who is the cause of
that and then we start attributing all
sorts of other things that we're not
actually experiencing to that Divine
being and then we read that back in to
the universe
um in effect imagining things that
aren't really there so he says that you
persisted imagining if we Grant the
Divine existence for which you earnestly
contend you may safely infer
consequences from it and add something
to the experienced order of nature by
arguing from the attributes that you
ascribe to your gods and this is a what
he says a gross sophism because you
don't actually know that much about God
because all you've got are the effects
that you can see in the universe so this
is this is a a problem here and and why
is he saying this Hume doesn't think
that there is any providential ordering
by a God but this is to show how
logically in his view it would be
you know disputable if not fallacious
there's another possibility
this is one that Many religious people
do take which is to claim that there is
some sort of afterlife and you know the
universe itself doesn't give us complete
justice but in that afterlife everything
is going to be reckoned and rectified
you could say so he says that
um what must a philosopher think of
those reasoners who instead of regarding
the present scene of things as a sole
object of their contemplation so far
reverse the whole course of Nature has
to render this life merely a passage to
something further a porch which leads to
a greater and vastly different building
a prologue which serves only to
introduce the peace and give it more
grace and propriety what are we talking
about there this is a very fancy way of
talking about
Heaven and Hell or some sort of
afterlife where there'd be a judgment
and he says where do philosophers derive
their idea of the Gods from their own
conceited imagination surely right and
you know so he he says we can actually
think about this
um mere possibility and hypothesis by
considering three different
possibilities
if there is distributive justice as he
says are there any marks of distributive
justice in the world if you answer in
the affirmative if you say yeah the
world is fair good people get good
outcomes bad people get bad outcomes
well then what the hell do you need an
afterlife to provide that stuff for
right you're already getting it in this
present life
what if you say well no no that's it's
not a fair World there isn't
distributive justice or whatever else
you want to call it people getting
rewarded or punished in this world
that's exactly why Heaven and Hell or
some sort of you know afterlife where
judgment takes place matters so much if
he says uh if you reply in the negative
I conclude you have no reason to ascribe
Justice in our sense of it to the Gods
why because you're arguing from what we
observe in the natural world to the
cause the gods or God but if it's not
there in the natural world then you
can't ascribe it to God so if even if
there is a God the God is not going to
be just and not fix things in the
afterlife what if you say yes and no
what if you adopt what Hume calls a
medium between affirmation and negation
saying that the Justice of the Gods at
present exerts itself in part but not in
its full extent and then he says well
I answer that you have no reason to give
it any particular extent but only so far
as you see it at present exert itself
that is in the universe so putting these
two together yes and no is not going to
get you what you're looking for
so this is a pretty you know strong
argument that he's providing here and
you know they go on a little bit further
in this this discussion and then you
know Hume suggests
um that you know maybe there could be
like an argument from design and his
friend combats that and he points
something out that is very important
both in you could say an epistemological
and a moral sense he says there's an
infinite difference of the subjects
between human beings and God you know
God uh we can't really know much about
the Divine infinite being because we
don't have experience that we can
analogize from you know we can't just
use human beings or anything so how much
goodness and Justice can we actually
attribute to the deity as much as we
actually see in the world
and maybe that's not an awful lot
we can't actually you know he says as
the universe shows wisdom and goodness
we infer wisdom and goodness as it shows
a particular degree of these Perfections
we infer a particular degree of them
precisely adapted to the effect we
examine but further attributes or
further degrees of the same attributes
we can never be authorized to infer
suppose by any rules of just reasoning
greater good produced by this being must
still prove a greater degree of goodness
a more impartial distribution of rewards
and punishment must proceed from a
greater regard to Justice and equity now
if we can't actually see this in the
world
then why are we attributing it to God
about whom if he exists we don't really
know much of anything and we cannot
analogize from you know human beings
because human Affairs are not analogous
to Divine Affairs and human beings are
not analogous to God
so you know he goes out and he says this
is the why we make this mistake right
he says that we consider ourselves as in
the place of the Supreme Being and we
conclude that he will on every occasion
observe the same conduct which we
ourselves in a situation would have
embraced as reasonable and eligible and
he says you know that's really an
illegitimate way to reason why he says
it must evidently appear contrary to all
rule of analogy to reason from the
projects and intentions of men to those
of a being so different and so much
Superior in human nature there is a
certain experienced coherence of divine
that designs and inclinations right so
we can as he pointed out in a previous
section we can argue from the human
beings that we know here to what it's
like in other cultures or other times we
cannot do that with a being that is so
radically different different as we
assume from our selves so you know that
kind of demolishes a lot of people's
approaches to claiming that there is
some sort of
well-distributed Justice because we know
God is super super just if Hume is right
about this and you know it's kind of an
open question whether he is in his
reasoning well then we we wouldn't be
able to ascribe that to God now he does
close this on an interesting note he
says
this is him talking to his friend there
is one circumstance which you seem to
overlook though I should allow your
premises I must deny your conclusion
you conclude
that religious doctrines and reasoning
can have no influence on life because
they
ought to have no influence never
considering that men reason not in the
same manner that you do but draw many
consequences from the belief of divine
existence and suppose that the deity
will inflict punishments on Vice and
bestow rewards on virtue beyond what
appear in the ordinary course of nature
whether this reasoning of theirs be just
or not it is no matter its influence on
their life and conduct must still be the
same what is human actually saying there
lots of people are terrible reasoners
and except all sorts of ideas from you
know religious doctrines or philosophies
that they have no business if they're
being you know uh truly reasonable
accepting well people do in fact do that
and so all these you know reasonings
that we have that would say well you
can't actually show that there's a
Providence or claim that there's a
Providence most people don't don't worry
about that at all they think that there
is and they're going to behave that way
so if that keeps the honest people
honest so to speak
Hume doesn't see a problem with that
it's not the best basis for good
behavior or you know proper motivations
but it is how many people do in fact
behave and so we see Hume coming to his
usual skeptical conclusions about these
sorts of things he attacks and perhaps
you know if you buy into his reasonings
demolishes the arguments that that most
people tend to make but he says that
doesn't actually have that great effect
on how people do in fact believe and
behave